what's your relationship to other
comedians you watch them do you learn
from them do you sure yeah I'm always a
student of comedy I really love watching
any comedian I'll watch any comedian and
just hear the you know it's like
studying the ocean or the way it's more
than it'sit's interesting to me because
I mean I'm fascinated by watching
painters have told me mmm-hmm they go to
the museum and they just look at it more
clinically yeah yeah yeah sure you're
saying that's how he did that I see that
look at that that's right
you do the same thing yeah and it's hard
to go out too I mean if I'm if I have
time to go like if I get a babysitter
and run to a club to do a set I might
watch the guy before me but then I got
to go home so I don't get to do that
like I used to when you start out when I
started I just I just devoured comedy I
went to clubs every night even if I
wasn't I'd be on stage maybe twice a
week but I was at Club seven nights a
week
I'd watch every comedian I could good or
bad friend or foe didn't matter I just
watched and and just loaded it into my
system as well I'm the same way about
you know I mean here's why see how they
do it are they doing it you're in London
watch everybody you can see right are
they doing it differently is there a
style that's interesting yeah Indian you
have to be yourself you have to find
your own sense but there's always
something to learn about the approach
that somebody maze whether it's a
baseball player watching another
baseball player right because the
baseball player is watching another
player but he's watching baseball he's
watching this they're all doing the same
game you know so the game is so the same
in stand-up whatever the comic is doing
is not in a vacuum you're watching
stand-up happen you're watching how
audiences are reacting and the audience
is such a mysterious animal to us you
know so you're always kept guessing
there's some nights you go to a club and
you're like you know I feel good I'm
ready to do I have a good show but the
audience has a strange unanimous grumpy
feeling to them or something and how did
all these people they're all strangers
to each other
but they've they're all sitting there we
hate this show like some common spots
yes oh I'll never see enough shows to go
okay I get this yeah you know so it's a
in an unquenchable thirst